نحن ايضا سنبقى بملفات كاس العالم لكن
سنعود بها الى الذاكره وقصه مثيره جدا اذ
لم يكن هيكتور كاسترو في حاجه الى اكثر من
ذراع واحد للتتويج بلقب كاس العالم مع
منتخب اوروغواي تعود تفاصيل القصه الى
عشرينيات وثنيات القرن الماضي تحديدا
النسخه الاولى للمونديال حين سجل هيكتور
كاسترو اول هدفا في تاريخ نهائيات كاس
العالم بيد مكسوره
الذي اصبح ملهما متذ ذلك الوقت للشعب
اوروغواي بترت يده بمنشار كهربائي كان
يستخدمه لتقطيع الاشجار وهو كان في سن
الثالث عشر من عمره ليفقد بذلك كده هم مدى
الحياه لكنه فقد يده لكن لم يفقد ايمانه
وشغفه بكره القدم اذا اصر حتى انضم الى
نادي ناشونال في اوروجواي الى ان استطع
نجمه ويتحقق ما هو بالانضمام الى منتخب
بلاده ثم قاده في اول نسخه من المونديال
والتي اقيمت ايضا في الاورغواي وفي اول
مباراه له في كاس العالم افتتح صاحب اليد
الواحده اهداف منتخب اوروغواي في كاس
العالم عبر التاريخ بعد ما سجل في مرمى
بيرو ليغيب بعدها عن المبارتين التاليتين
امام رومانيا ويوغسلافيا السابقه في نصف
النهائي اما في المباراه النهائيه كانت
النتيجه تشير الى تقدم اوروغواي على
الارجنتين بثلاثه اهداف لاثنين وسط ضغط
مكثف المنتخب التانجو من اجل التعادل الا
ان هيكتور كاسترو سجل هدف منتخب بلاده
الرابع في الدقيقه التاسعه والثمانين
ليحسم الامور ويقود منتخب بلاده الى
التتويج باول نسخه من كاس العالم
وليثبت اسمه وقصته في تاريخ اللعبه
[موسيقى]